she looking some the company okay I had
to verify let's see here is that another
carbon fight no the rare pool yes madam
here okay all right oh yes and I get in
here oh and it would be followed now wow
this is the coolest [ __ ] I probably ever
seen what is that like mascara VidCon
there I hope I'm just return the tape
the lumen place probably bike and we
made it across kuberan followed I have
some pretty good information for you but
first we'll need to take the necessary
precautions okay just hold still no
don't will hurt you a lot lower than it
will hurt you know don't do it aside
when you are ready please help oh mama
dress oh the guts you clown there's a
drummer couch over there I can't no
wonder they're listening to all my
conversations all right listen Karen I'm
listening I'm listening this resort it's
all fake I just softer we are all
characters enough soon you wanna take
this game but I just told her the way
out of here find the mechanical work oh
it's in a piglet and cook it it will
lead you to freedom take this oh good
the natives use it for hunting good boy
Godspeed all alike Godspeed we've seen
it where is it I've seen it
there it is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] over here to get [ __ ] a
roasted your [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm at the
roast your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] good good
good let's get out of here adios
muchachos ah [ __ ] escape that what works
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is getting very tricky oh
my god this is like such a turn-on mmm
mmm I think and and oh wow there are you
here okay a little better than any other
pieces oh yes right here machine
incredible alright sorry think I fixed
you [ __ ] just getting weird um yes yes
okay I'm just whiner Oh take care thank
you yeah [ __ ] people ah [ __ ]
reddit do i can't i can't really fun you
can't play oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] scary
um I gotta go this way where's that bun
dip I gotta get to the top I'm guessing
right
how far Oh [ __ ] far that's kind of
scary oh ok which way to there oh [ __ ]
ok I'm gone I'm gone again not here I
mean
what oh yeah get me out of here get me
out of here the [ __ ] okay Matty I'm out
of here I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on that's so scary i'm check out
to be real quick she's like waiting for
me huh what
please have a seat we've not business to
discuss wait this is all fake you
[ __ ] deer pi blanket prints on the
process of being kidnapped we've taken
your friends if you wish to see them
again come to 128 pleasant ave it's
worse where is it I would like you may
remember me from the resort hotel yeah I
don't know how you escaped I'm taking
our precious director suffered a city
was just a mirage please come to 128
doesn't happen to do this message will
self-destruct in five [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he got here what is that to get
perfume thing save the director okay i
love the thug named and it didn't think
some people oh I'm like a pest inspector
guy yes oh ok ok then pit them n ty ty
ty ty ty ty they're disgusting I'm
basically one of the best detectives
that ever left ok
what
oh sorry didn't mean to do that so
inclined whoa really cool place okay
mess up their helmet ha kodesh how's my
brother how's my wrap it could be better
remember whenever they were really
little area a little levity oh you die
let's see this this place is so nice
Wow amazing okay ah yeah it's still nice
orange I got ya hey like that baby Cat
Cat there was so much fun here we go you
are video shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah sure um how do that huh I
have 43 burns all over my entire face
okay nothing do it rain
okay okay absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] up but
yes yeah [ __ ] hate [ __ ] like this
okay and yeah kidding set what's the
most expensive thing here oh good guy
get cought stocking it's good I'll take
that okay oh [ __ ] you thank you
angular white n red oh good good yellow
left n 30 I tried okay okay now what is
my oh that is a [ __ ] nice pool what
the [ __ ] is that a hammerhead shark
these people are disgustingly rich okay
what's the game plan I like to know now
am I supposed to just get out of here
save the director if I was the director
Oh boobs um what can I put there okay I
up in there right and you can really did
it keep the bottle now now get get get
weekend hey I want an autopsy none of us
keep on drinking
okay I gotta get [ __ ] up now don't
look back there's a way how to get get
okay Oh areas behind you know over here
no no I'll it a little more I'm a bit
more uh and this is sitting a little to
your left no your your other oh oh oh go
back go back of it there hailey stop yes
hey Barry all right let's but it's a
Christmas ha Holly black we've been
expecting you of course okay register
you've taken something of mine and so
I've taken something of yours do we take
a hearse that's the other big case
they've taken some of you and it's
imperative that you get me behind a rock
hands I my own improvise I know you do
well for me hmm really black I challenge
you to a game of of course of course is
to us should you prove victorious I will
free the director unharmed as I wanted
ice road this is hey this is Carl first
I guarantee you there won't be a one
hint of foul play
you [ __ ] [ __ ] home run I must be a
bit off today the other Impala bank
please select the sports tick of your
choice that almost went with that one
myself this game is reg this games right
I'll tell you hon okay oh that's what
he's he's stuck in its alright a cheat
Oh is a shark in here Thank good and is
this what is this guy to always doing
here just drawing on Jesus and I see a
one-sided fun this spring sexiest gags
okay um there's got to be a way to do
this whole let me just check our real
quick this is how we're gonna escape but
just Aaron okay ready
oh [ __ ] all right shut take [ __ ]
inverted okay the consequences are in
your hands it is a ganja time jesus
Oh up
get get get a lot of cars Jesus all
right let's say I'd say I stop it okay
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I was so surprised
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] all you people
are [ __ ] cheaters Oh it'd be good SS
which we're gonna jump off a [ __ ]
cliff all right it was never need for
that ridiculous ass parade with a sucker
all she says don't let it get you down
for a blank
okay I you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] a okay
okay it's probably like here y'all
[ __ ] [ __ ] how the [ __ ] this is
Rick cheating okay we're getting warmed
up please follow me and let us begin
gauntlet [ __ ] is the gauntlet that's
where tell us what it seems they've got
me suspended in some sort of a mystery
cool it was there soon as any golf
coffee with what the [ __ ] just happened
okay I Gary Radnich
you
whoa
what the [ __ ]
oh I like that massages said water polo
this next course will require some
recreation of the coagulant colloquially
known as short gravy please grab a
little control hair for the gym beating
of a lifetime simply oh my god this is
insane he's a madman I tell you he needs
help he needs help oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't you know I love gravy
don't you know I'm an expert in gravy
chef I'm gonna crush this fool because
he messed with the wrong piece of gravy
why don't you be touching old stuff I
don't know
and I'm crashing this [ __ ] that's just
the gravy master you know I have to say
I three honest like well I've known I've
always been great at gravy like I'm not
the biggest gripe you fan you know okay
i want i want sex today you're not
supposed to be able to win this and on
to the next course yet these are good
because we go and I case the [ __ ] is
that this guy [ __ ] psychopath
ok 150ma I love gravy get my vehicle
this i Ken [ __ ]
oh the ego meters down good is this I'll
tell me we're gonna do this this however
I must warn you i'm quite the matrix
maverick or some like to call me the
video virtuoso that base all right let's
say [ __ ] I'm the king of the words
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucks to be you [ __ ]
keeping the net
all right okay now I got you actually
have to look look where if your [ __ ]
okay and very frustrated mindful you
should be best Chris there oh ok 44 took
me a while to warm up but never I got it
champion [ __ ] let's see the emea drop
let's see it I prefer to call this
reverse winning oh he's read his face is
red hot [ __ ] to calibrate this thing
there's no way you should have been able
to win that way that trophy if he would
be so kind as the head of my phone [ __ ]
you [ __ ] give me the start
Oh synaptic seat bench uh-oh
what is out the stuff oh I have to like
be the champion you can hop in the water
is permanent heart five or six
worshipper Oh cyclotron liquefied
genocide oh very dark so thirsty okay
there's nothing preferably somewhere
isn't it another pressure me oh yeah you
headed oh I don't deserve another trophy
for me he's gonna pop this [ __ ] is
gonna pop you know by 10 lives mostly
prevention what up this once
oh I think I put this on his back and
then it's like shooting it what the [ __ ]
would I do there oh I gotta give them
the last face I feel like a capsule salt
is that is so it looks like I want time
to save the director that [ __ ] I do it
oh this is so crazy oh oh this is
horrifying
anyway away on my way let me have to
save you a doctor there to save you hey
so doctors ready for you okay good thank
you thank you I'll have complete faith
that you can do this motorbike let's say
no so you some I can still do what
that's gonna do I mean you might recall
in my mouth now because it's only gonna
end one way oh-ho face no Sarah this is
getting Trippier by the second looks
that way oh what a hug is that this is a
butthole oh it's over it's over wow what
a good game Thank you Thank You IRA
thank you for playing it up welcome
welcome are we going to the bottle I
think we're going to the bug eyes
get out of you get ten tips yes very
good okay is that the real but all I
suggest apologies Elvis is sick recorded
here in the event that i ever get
transmogrified into a man that are
offered and you need to escape allowed
vintage model justice system are
providing specially encoded missional
which is the key locations are affecting
running oh and are just a warning i have
a particularly violent immune system
that's the truck has shed also please
stay calm all secretary be fine all
right oh oh yeah caballo did you learn
it took leadership dodo dodo dodo dodo
dodo did it do alright that y'all be
able for watching okay okay thanks apply